gérard dorwling carter bonjour je
regarde travail à vue merci d'être avec
nous ce matin
vous allez nous parler de deux
associations tout cas des actions que
vous menez au sein de ces deux
associations que vous présidez
alors l'association patrimoine
martinique sera pour la fin d'interview
et puis l'association tous créoles alors
vous avez été co président gérard dans
l'hymne carter dès la création en 2007
de cette association tous créoles
c'est une association qui a été
controversée on y reviendra peut-être
mais longtemps c'est l'autre co
président le défunt roger de jaham qui a
été son visage emblématique 1 depuis son
décès il ya trois ans est ce qu'on peut
dire que l'association se cherche un
nouveau souffle vous nous le dire est en
tout cas voilà qu'à l'issue d'une
assemblée générale le 25 juillet dernier
vous avez été élu à l'unanimité
président provisoire est donc à la tête
d'une équipe dirigeante tout aussi
provisoire qu'est-ce que vous êtes allé
faire dans cette nouvelle aventure
gérard d'or une carte je ne suis pas
allé on est venu me chercher dans la
mesure où on m'a mis en face de mes
obligations
on m'a expliqué qu'il ya une quinzaine
d'années j'avais eu l'idée avec roger de
jaham feu roger de jaham de créer cette
association à une époque où certainement
que les conditions de vie étaient
certainement détérioré sur le plan le
plan des relations humaines sein de
cette communauté martiniquais et
effectivement depuis la mort de roger
qui était une véritable locomotive les
choses stagnent s et siaulai quoi que
l'association avait quand même une épine
dorsale les activités un nombre
substantiel de membres et il m'a été
demandé de redynamiser
la capacité ce challenge qui m'a été
proposé et que j'ai été obligé de alors
pourquoi provisoire parce que le conseil
d'administration a démissionné
les deux coprésidents réalise mon bain
et il d'aider arrivés au terme de leur
mandat et que ce sens sans que ses
prédécesseurs postulent à de nouvelles
fonctions 3 - trois membres dont j'ai
toujours été membre sans être parmi les
dirigeants
après un certain temps trois membres ont
pour fonction de d'étudier la situation
de fait des propositions l'état sauf que
la société
l'association bardon redémarre alors je
disais qu'est-ce que vous êtes allé
fernand dans cette nouvelle aventure
dans le contexte que nous connaissons
alors peut-être que cela va ressembler
plus à priori à une petite traversée en
galère qu'une qu'une croisière
tranquille mons à l'avenir le dira mais
on n'a pas beaucoup entendu
l'association tous créoles ces temps
derniers 1 puisque il y a eu quand même
un certain nombre d'événements beaucoup
de discours autour de tout ça bon on
sait alors qu' il faut rappeler que
l'association tous créoles a été fondée
fectivement en 2007 par une soixantaine
de personnes issues de toutes les
composantes de la population
martiniquaise la communauté créole
antillaise même comme il est dit sur sur
le site même de de tous créoles donc
désigné comme noirs mulâtres indiens
chinois baic et syro libanais mais aussi
des métropolitains des africains etc
ayant adopté depuis longtemps
la créolité comme démarche de vie et de
pensée et on va rajouter que l'objectif
de l'association l'objectif initial de
tous créoles c'est de permettre aux
martiniquais et aux martiniquais aux
autres communauté créole au delà
d'histoire douloureuse de leur origine
de se retrouver dans l'apaisement d'une
personnalité partager balle aurait dû
vous entendre davantage là c'est ton
dernier du moment où il avait été décidé
de marquer un temps d'arrêt et de
demander à cette commission n'ont pas
n'était à venir sur le champ médiatique
ou sociétales vous pourrez t'on dire
mais de réfléchir à une nouvelle
dynamique à sion de l'association qui
avait demandé absolument besoin de ce
réglage il n'était pas question
d'intervenir à tout bout de champ
d'ailleurs à ce sujet je voudrais
expliquer que la controverse dans
donc vous avez parlé bertrand à propos
de tout ce qui est simplement né du fait
que roger déjà un petit guerrier et je
salue son courage et son sang netapp
estivités parce que c'est parfois
nécessaire
sélestat enferré dans un an dans une
stratégie de deux permanentes défense et
de mise au point un peu plus mature et
lui chercher querelle c'est ce que va t
on prendre plus de recul et de parler
dans l'arène ce camp là où il ya le
combat pour lui pour sa personne et ça
ça semblait être le bouclier de la
communauté békée et l'association a
semblé être copié les serviteurs alors
la page est tournée
roger de jaham s'en est allé aujourd'hui
compte tenu des défis nous voir le v&o
et ça se sait ce que vous dites un c'est
le nouveau credo un petit peu peut-être
de tous créoles
compte tenu des défis nous voir lever au
regard des soubresauts de nos sociétés
créoles en quête identitaire on l'a vu
c'est encore le cas justement tous
créoles a le devoir de se réinventer
c'est le lot de missions mais ce n'est
pas très difficile ça n'aide pas ne pas
réagir systématiquement sauter à coups
de communiqués pour fustiger vous
dénoncez les activités ceci et cela
c'est le bas être célèbre des écrivains
publics mais c'est de réfléchir au fond
docks de la société pas des yeux d'yves
est assez classique quoi dîner débat
conférence analyse dossier publication
de ce qu'est la trame de ce que le test
c'est une association qui a vocation à
porter quand même un message public à
intervenir bon c'est vrai vous pouvez
faire des réunions réfléchir ça c'est
pas mal mais alors quand même où se
manifestent un peu plus encore des
crispations des tensions voire même
parfois de sérieuses frictions donc de
tout ça à roland communautaire faisant
référence à l'origine ou à
l'appartenance à des groupes spécifiques
etc
quel est le message que peut porter
l'association tous créoles n'ont aucun
de ces événements en tous les cas je
sois sympa ça sera pas une réactivité
immédiate immédiate et systématique sera
pas un jugement à l'emporte-pièce ça
sera pas les idées toutes faites
ce sera pas ça sera pas la solution
l'explication simple est simple était
pas que c'était ce qui s'est passé
auparavant
mais ce sera ou simpliste ce sera une
façon différente plus philosophique plus
profonde de comprendre ce qui se passe
alors eux on voit aussi que les
évènements de ces derniers deux semaines
de ces derniers mois et est lié certains
mêmes disent qu'il est née du scandale
de l' usage massif et prolongé d'au delà
du raisonnable de la chlordécone ce qui
a vous en conviendrez agité les esprits
de pas mal de martiniquaise et de
martiniquais voire même secoué les âmes
un petit peu et donc collectivement je
veux dire voilà ça fait ressurgir des
souvenirs des réminiscences d'une
domination d'un groupe sur un autre
est-ce que cela vous le comprenez vous
qui est actuellement président
provisoire de tous créoles
non ce que je ce que je ne comprends pas
c'est qu'il ya de cela une trentaine
d'années quand pierre davidas est venu
me vois que nous avons commencé à faire
des caravanes et à travailler sur la
question du chlordécone
je ne m'en vante pas mais je profite de
l'occasion quand ce soir il s'agit ni
par sa petite maison avec des
agriculteurs les wii des jeux qui nous
rapporter ce qui s'est passé par pau
chlordécone canton se rapprocher des
mets à l'époque de se rapprocher des
services publics
on avait un silence total mais depuis ce
jour là beaucoup d'entre nous ne buvant
que de l'eau que de l'eau de l'eau
minérale on ne touche pas l'eau du
robinet on le savait les solutions à
l'époque était simple c'était changer le
mode de fixation de l'eau c'était
peut-être tempéré ceux qui abusent passé
ce qu'il aurait fallu faire mais ça n'a
pas été fait mais voilà le résultat
aujourd'hui
pour résumer c'est aussi l'heure des
oeillères beaucoup de gens disent bombe
et chez point année nous quoi oui c'est
simpliste peut-être comme vous le dites
vous le dire en fait honneur aux textes
existent qu'ils pensent vraiment alors
dans le quart d'heure c'est pas ma façon
de me déposer le voleur est ce qu'on va
régler le problème du de la chlordécone
ce que depuis ça s'est féminisé en
essayant de trouver des coupables en
essayant de criminaliser en essayant de
faire des procès en essayant de se
secouer dans la rue et de fanions
partout cet avocat professionnellement
kova oui je crois qu'on va régler plein
de l'apport des connes embêtant des
investissements fondamentaux il s'avère
que c'est difficile de briser cette
molécule
et quand elle est brisée il a été
découvert récemment qu'elle se fragmente
par la nature mais qu'elle a dit cet
opposant sa plus dangereuse mais c'est
le sac il faut qu'on soit qu'on s'occupe
c'est pas de d'essayer de chercher des
poux la tête du voisin
estelle ordinaux gave autorisé pourquoi
comme si d'ordino et voulu absolument
pas aux dés la population martiniquaise
donc là vous vous êtes favorable à ce
qu'on change un peu de logiciels en tout
cas d' approche et c'est un problème est
on en train de s'agiter autour plutôt
que de réellement passé ensemble tel
coller à la résolution du problème
quelques mots de l'autre association
dont vous êtes président l'association
patrimoine martini qui nous restent
faibles et les exécutants commission
viendra avec vous maroc qui avait été
constitué qui avait été créée par la
vice présidente de l'assemblée de la
collectivité territoriale martiniquaise
avec pour objectif mon plaisir oui elle
m'a baisé pour thème la réhabilitation
du patrimoine au service de l'économie
ou le brésil via sa l'économie au
service des actions et les alisation
déjà commencé livres pour des bréviaires
de vade mecum est prévu pour expliquer
aux gens comment qu'elle lui au
téléphone comme on faire pour agir pour
conserver le patrimoine antique
nous y reviendrons gérard dans l'hymne
carter nous avons essentiellement parlé
de tous créoles puisque il y à peu vous
avez été élu président provisoire mais
président néanmoins de cette association
merci bonne journée et bon week-end l'on
sait déjà c'est tout c'est moi que vous
remercie